the Joe Rogan experience now I know that
you're big on this - you're you're big
on tribe like you have like those guys
that you travel with we do shows with
this is like a tribe of you like yeah a
community and it's very important I
respect that I think that's very that's
huge so that's it but it's the thing
I've learned from my interactions with
you and the thing I've seen is you don't
you don't parade it around and you don't
talk about too much but you do talk
about that there are some things where
you just you put up some firewalls in
your life and the people that you're
around and I have heard you refer to at
times that that something got to someone
was maybe like too damaging and
referring to people that it wasn't even
like you were condemning them or thought
they were bad but you just refer to like
times you've had like just sort of
protect what you had and what what you
care about and just make some things not
part of your life anymore yeah you have
to do that sometimes yeah you have to
you have to realize that there's some
people that are not looking out for
themselves some people don't make that
jump well and they keep that around yeah
they keep that that influence around
because it because of maybe like
misplaced loyalties yeah so I've noticed
you bring that up a handful of times we
were like something just got to be where
you had like build you just you had to
be like you I love you respect you would
ever buy just gotta protect these other
things well some people get some
completely self-absorbed and they burn
everything around them because they're
only thinking about themselves and even
if you love them and care them or
appreciate what they're doing like some
people are amazing at certain things
like you know we're talking about
Hendrix
I mean if Hendrix did beat his wife I
know if that's true or beat his
girlfriend's you know but it's like some
people are so good at what they do that
like that's all they're thinking about
and they didn't develop these
interpersonal skills or relationship
skills or you know whatever it's you
know they didn't develop a sense of
nuance in terms of their perspective of
the world or a sense of introspective
thinking whether they're looking at
themselves and being objective about how
they interface with the people around
them and
and life those people that are just like
wholly focused on the south especially
pure narcissists which you run into a
lot of them in show business and some of
them it's not their fault you know you
talk to me if you believe in determinism
you know and you believe that they're a
product of all the things that have
happened to them and then you run down
the list of all the things that have
happened to them it's [ __ ]
bone-chilling I mean so many people that
I know particularly in show business are
there because of just a giant hole they
developed in their self-esteem and
there's who they are as a child they
didn't get enough love they got too much
abuse and hate and bullying and all
these varying factors that made them
push so hard to achieve success to let
everybody know hey I am special hey I am
something you were all wrong and then
the but along the way they they burn
everything around them yeah and it's I
don't I don't you know I mean I don't
want to it's it's possible to get there
without that that's what I want to say
it's like it's possible to get there
without being a piece of [ __ ] and some
people think you have to be a piece of
[ __ ] to be successful you don't don't
have to or I think some people get to
where remember earlier I mentioned like
the collateral damage yeah I some people
think have you could develop such an
inflated sense of what you're bringing
to the world that you it's you
personally come to accept the idea that
there is a price to pay yeah that price
being other people yeah
yeah that's a problem but then again if
you don't have certain standards than
other people to chew up all your time
and their problems become your problems
and they don't even thinking about their
problems they're thinking about you
thinking about their problems I mean
there's many people that pawn off their
problems on other folks and they think
that if you're a good friend you're
helping me like you're not a good friend
you're not taking care of me you're not
helping me like you're helping yourself
yeah the [ __ ] are you doing for yourself
like this is a trap that a lot of people
get stuck into it's codependency it
happens in a lot of relationships
there's a lot of people that get
involved in relationships boy and girl
that they find that the person who is
their their soulmate is also the source
of all their [ __ ] problems and
they're the curator of this person's
life they're that they're supposed to be
like helping this person along because
this person is like Dean
them the person who's most important to
them and it's like you know you got to
find you got to find out what you know
what is the what's the boundary where
you won't cross or you don't realize
like someone is becoming an impediment
to your own happiness and success
it's amazing the degree to which people
deep down do care about what someone is
quote like you know mm-hmm where I find
that because I've been on your show a
number of times people are curious about
you and people will often ask me oh you
know what's wrong and really like but
they know they know that they know what
answer they want to hear bad people
would love a story okay you think us I'm
like Oprah Winfrey I've found that
people love a story about how bad like
people are gonna eat up a story that
she's awful yeah yeah sure like people
want a story about some of you bad but
what's funny about what you've done and
how you've done it is it and this
happens quite often where people are
like they're like he's a good guy right
like they wanted to know like they feel
like you are and they want to have a
confirm not that they're like oh yeah
tell me the story about him being bad
like they would with a lot of people if
someone has a really bad story about
Oprah I'm like oh I'm all yours course
why well well I think first of all
because Oprah is enormous ly successful
like in some sort of preposterous way
yeah what's a billion dollars were just
talking she can't saying she can't dance
it's not in good shape what is she doing
it's just talking she's got a billion
dollars [ __ ] her I hope she's I hope
she's a meanie
I hope she's doing terrible yeah you
know there's a thing about that it's
like you want to find it oh she got that
way because she's [ __ ] people over
yeah I heard she beats her assistant
Archy I mean her sisters have a it makes
sense of the world so Wow in some ways
like you want to think that someone
who's achieved that ridiculous level of
success is mean I got passed by Oprah
Oprah has a house in Montecito I passed
by the house like that is a ridiculous
house
person it's like a giant lawn 50 million
dollar house a [ __ ] huge estate it's
a castle she's a queen you know you
don't want that like [ __ ] her you know
you know my house is 250 grand why is it
what the [ __ ] is she doing with that 50
and that's not even how she lives in she
just visits that like once a year takes
a [ __ ] there has someone cooked for
takes a nap gets up stirs an animosity
stirs and animosity yeah well you know
preposterous success breeds animosity
and that lady's got a lot of
preposterous success you know certain
people you meet them you want him to sit
like dr. Phil like he's a similar thing
I would be receptive to a bad dr. Phil
I'm sorry he's great dr. Phil is [ __ ]
great my friend Jay is dr. Phil's son I
became friends with dr. Phil through
another guy through another guy because
my friend Ron white my friend Ron white
is a good buddy minds when the best
comedians on earth is good friends with
OJ mcgraw who's dr. Phil's son so I
became friends with Jay before I became
friends with dr. Phil then I had dr.
Phil on the podcast dr. Phil's the
[ __ ] nicest guy ever he's a regular
guy like you hang out and talk to him
he's got a ridiculous amount of success
but he's hilarious he's like a regular
dude
[Applause]